L'informatique responsable se définit
comme le développement de l'informatique quantique
en ayant conscience de sa puissance
et de ses impacts potentiels. Quand on parle de responsabilité,
il faut développer et utiliser la technologie
en s'appuyant sur des principes prédéfinis pour nous aider à prévenir
et à atténuer les risques potentiels,
tout en promouvant des solutions qui sont de manière proactive
inclusives et responsables. Chez IBM,
nous sommes guidés par un sens des responsabilités
envers la société depuis des décennies. Aujourd'hui, nous nous définissons comme un catalyseur
qui améliore le fonctionnement du monde. Cela signifie que nous
avons la responsabilité de considérer les implications des
technologies que nous construisons et aidons à mettre en œuvre.
Alors que nous développons cette nouvelle technologie,
les décisions que nous prenons aujourd'hui influenceront l'avenir,
et ces décisions
ont le potentiel d'avoir un impact immense sur la société.
Par exemple, tu pourrais avoir à choisir entre poursuivre une application
qui ne profite qu'à quelques parties prenantes ou
une qui pourrait résoudre un problème sociétal.
Nous espérons que toi, en tant que client, seras en mesure de réfléchir
au développement responsable de l'informatique quantique.
Penser de manière responsable peut aider ton entreprise à établir la confiance
avec les investisseurs et les consommateurs,
tout en construisant une réputation d'intégrité
et d'admiration auprès de tes employés
et de tes clients. D'un autre côté,
cela peut te protéger des mauvaises presses, des amendes
et des pénalités. Dans cette vidéo,
nous allons présenter les considérations importantes en matière de responsabilité
à discuter avec ton équipe
pendant que tu explores l'informatique quantique
et ses applications. En ce qui concerne l'informatique quantique,
penser et agir de manière responsable
signifie suivre un ensemble de principes
et de valeurs pour guider ton développement
et le déploiement de la technologie.
Par exemple, cela signifie être transparent
à la fois sur les limitations et les capacités
de l'informatique quantique actuelle. Nous avons du langage
dans nos contrats qui exige des clients d'IBM Quantum
d'utiliser nos systèmes de manière responsable
et de ne pas utiliser nos systèmes
à des fins néfastes ou illégales.
Nous appelons ces clauses notre utilisation responsable
et nos clauses d'utilisation acceptable.
Ce langage influence déjà la manière dont nos clients réfléchissent
au développement du quantique
pour leurs cas d'utilisation. Nous pouvons
aussi contribuer à orienter la direction de l'informatique quantique
en décidant quelles applications nous poursuivons
pour le développement et l'accélération.
Afin de se protéger contre les utilisations potentiellement irresponsables
de notre technologie, nous avons aussi développé une technologie IBM Quantum robuste
et sécurisée. Alors que tu réfléchis à comment
et pour quoi utiliser l'informatique quantique,
assure-toi d'exprimer de manière réaliste tes attentes
concernant l'informatique quantique et les délais
dans lesquels tu espères intégrer le quantique.
Ne présente pas l'informatique quantique
comme quelque chose de mystérieux ; essaie plutôt de l'expliquer de façon réaliste
comme un matériel informatique
qui suit les règles de la physique quantique.
Assure-toi que ton cas d'utilisation de l'informatique quantique
est de manière proactive inclusif
et prend en compte toutes les parties prenantes potentielles
pour déterminer l'ampleur
de tout impact sociétal négatif.
Assure-toi d'avoir défini des principes clairs
et des valeurs pour l'exploration de ton cas d'utilisation
et son développement. Merci
d'avoir regardé. Nous espérons que,
alors que tu apportes l'informatique quantique utile au monde,
tu penseras aussi à comment faire cela de manière responsable.
Euh, euh.